what was it that drew both of you to
this line of work I think by accident
Edmond worked in advertising that's what
he thought he was going to be swinging
adman all his life
so could you imagine he could get out of
Africa and get to London you know he'd
get to the top
well after we emigrated to America we
then then we got a project which was
travel cassettes for TWA and it was
during the course of researching those
those cassettes and writing them that we
discovered that we liked writing about
people and he then got an agent and she
said oh she said we know a publisher who
wants a short popular biography of
Theodore Roosevelt
are you game for that oh yes absolutely
I'd love to do that he knew nothing
about Theodore Roosevelt very little
really about American history at that
point they wanted a short biography
short popular biography which turned
into a trilogy you know and wanting the
Pulitzer Prize in the American Book
Award to boot so that's how we really
drifted into our line of work I was
helping him type his manuscript on
Theodore rose wood and I said what about
this woman he married nothing's known
about her he said so that was sort of
throwing down the gauntlet to me and I
said well I'll look into it and I did
and found that she was quite fascinating
and what a wonderful team as it turned
out I mean that's fantastic
mm-hmm he won't end up writing seven
books and I wrote three and ten
altogether it's not a bad record really
ya know especially when they're of the
quality that they are yes and also the
extensive research that was required for
them and particularly the reagan book
because he had to follow him around at
the White House for four years you know
now that book was so controversial what
how does that how does all that sit with
you and how did it sit with him toward
the end he'd probably tell you it was
favorite book he would because he wanted
to do something different you say he
said biography was so stick-in-the-mud
in a way it was sort of birth to death
and he just wanted a new a new way of
doing it
somebody observing the person everything
in that word in that book
Kru about Reagan but he pretended that
he knew him in school and he knew him in
college and there was somebody watching
him very closely in those years of
course it's all based on research but
letters the Reagan wrote in those years
that of course got the the critics very
exercised yes I think it's his greatest
work what did you think of that idea
when he first said - well first I was
horrified of course but I really wanted
he wanted to change the way biographies
were done yes what is Edmunds legacy I
think his legacy will be a he was a
great biographer but also he was willing
to make changes in the structure of the
work do something original hadn't been
done before I think that would be his
greatest pride in his work that takes
courage and it takes courage yes and
you've got to be prepared that the
critics are not going to be kind but you
feel you have the conviction if you have
that conviction it's what you should do
you go ahead anyway and he did it and he
did a bunch of a bunch of time including
now no I can't help but think that he
but and and you were both so fascinated
by these these people these famous
people in history who were so bold and
made so many changes and I think that
that's that's what this work is all
about - yes I hadn't thought of it like
that but you have a good point there
that he shook up the genre in which he
worked he did something different that
he knew wouldn't be popular with many
people but he felt biography needed a
little shaking up I think
we know the work of Edmund the author
and the biographer what do you want
people to know about Edmund the person
his versatility for one thing for
example he was so good at music you see
and when I met him he was still thinking
of being a concert pianist and I said
well look why don't you go down to
Trinity College in London and just sign
up for the course there must be a course
on concert pianist and so he went and he
came back in short order and I said well
did you sign up and he said no I was
about to go into the building and I
suddenly realized he said if people
criticized my piano playing it didn't
bother me all that much but if they
criticize my writing I got extremely
upset and that's the way he made the
choice but when I met him he was still
hankering to be a concert pianist how
did the two of you meet you really want
to know this story well I had actually
been in America for two and a half years
on my own I did the usual thing as the
West Coast makes it go the trips and so
well I better go back to England now
since I'm English
so I went back to England take up my
former teaching job and I took a room in
a house in Merida burn in London and the
woman who are in the house said oh by
the way she said you may find when you
come home some nights there'll be
somebody cleaning there the house it's a
young man who in exchange for being able
to play my piano every lunchtime he
comes from his ogilvy & mather
job and he plays the piano for an hour
lunchtime I told well when did I eat I
mean really so the week goes by or two
and I'm opening a bathroom door one one
evening and I see this man kneeling on
the floor polishing it and I thought to
myself oh he does floors I wonder if he
does windows I literally thought that
isn't that weird
well we go by and one night he came down
to say good night he thought to his
employer and I was in the kitchen about
to make dinner
and I said oh she's not here at the
moment and then I noticed he was
carrying a paper bag and I said what are
you having that back he said oh it's my
dinner I said Oh what is it let me see
so I look in and it's a slice of Lyons
Corner a poor pie that was dinner and I
said this is not nutritious you're
really suffering from malnutrition if
you're eating like this he said oh I
wonder why the hairs were falling out of
my legs so I said sit down I make you an
omelette
I made him honor well as they say way to
a man's heart is through his stomach
right so you married the house cleaner I
thought but of course as soon as he got
married is two different stories up at
the desk already all right can turn my
well working okay yes I think what what
he's left behind in what you have worked
on here is it's so special and I think
it's something that a lot of people want
to hear about and I just find it
interesting the it's just it's it's the
dedication and it's also just the
conviction to stay with something no
matter how complicated or difficult that
was like it just seems like he was on
[Music]
unbending right yes both of you I think
I think he he would have called it not
stubbornness so much or unbending but
wanting to do something unusual to do
something in a different way that will
shake up the genre it isn't where
biography